good morning John Halloween uh-huh
in the spirit of the times I'm dressed
up like the mad scientist dr. horrible
but John I'll tell you what there's
another reason why I'm dressed apply
your hot scientists today and it's very
simple I guess dr. horrible doesn't wear
glasses huh except now I can't see
anything okay I'm gonna try this without
my glasses I feel very disoriented I am
also just like a mad scientist because
today
everyone watching this is being invited
to be part of the scientific experiment
I got a wipe the snot off my nose but I
don't want to do with my gloves I'm a
runny nose type of guy all that talk
about how awesome communities can be
when they come together to do awesome
things I've gotten people thinking and
one person dr. Suzanne Martin actually
contacted me about using the
nerdfighters as part of a scientific
experiment dr. Martin is studying the
interaction between our ears and our
eyes and she's got this excellent
software that tracks the motion of the
eyes and based on a large samples in
this study they can interpolate a lot of
different things about how our hearing
interacts with our seeing of the world
now this is really very cool stuff but
what they need is a lot of people
participating and it's since it's
expensive to get a bunch people into the
lab and doing this stuff she's actually
figured out a way to sort of outsource
that and so she is outsourcing it today
to our community I mean this is awesome
I can't believe that we are able to help
with science right here on YouTube
science dr. Martin and her conversation
with me was a little bit skeptical about
the idea that we would get enough videos
for a good sample size but I told her do
not underestimate the power of this
community so y'all don't let me down
here she needs a lot of these minimum
200 preferably like four figures like a
thousand videos so the rest of this
video is going to be the experimental
what you need in order to participate is
one a camera with which you can record
yourself so that the software can track
where your eyes are looking and you will
need very simply to watch the rest of
this video about a foot away from your
monitor now you have to have the camera
set up so that it can see your eyes
moving so your eye sight camera will
work or if you're using another camera
set it up so that it can see the whites
and blacks of your eyes it's all
amazingly simple and once you're done
recording yourself all you have to do is
post the videos response to this video
and then dr. Martin's research team can
download all that stuff via keepvid and
then analyze the eye movements with
their software so though since the video
pause right now get everything set up
start recording and then press play okay
are you back
are you done setting it up if you're not
thunk setting it up go set it up okay
here comes the video all you have to do
is follow with a little red dot with
your eyes about a foot away from the
screen with the YouTube player either
normal or HD sighs not fullscreen
ah
[Music]
hahahaha happy Halloween I apologize I
wasn't very nice I totally tricked you
what do you expect
I'm dr. horrible you think that the
ethics is gonna get in the way of the
science okay it's not officially science
but we do now have hopefully a very
large database of people getting scared
by a cat and I'm very much looking
forward to downloading all those videos
and then writing a song about how I
scared you so while we're not really
doing science we are using the power of
community to do something awesome and
what is Halloween without a little bit
of fright John don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]